>> RABBAT: Hi and welcome all to Bootcamp,
IO Bootcamp. Today we'll be talking about
optimizing web performance for success. My
co-presenters are Andrew Oates and Shawn Ligocki.
I'M Richard Rabbat. And we will be taking
turns. But first agenda, I will be motivating
why one needs to pay attention to speed, motivating
it obviously by revenue. Everybody is very
interested in making money on the web. Then
Andrew will be talking about a new API that
we're releasing today which is the Page Speed
Online API. He will have a really cool demo
about it. And finally, Shawn will be presenting
mod_pagespeed which is an Apache module that
allows you to speed up your webpages automatically.
So performance equals revenue. Let's talk
a little bit about what's been happening with
webpages over the past few months. This is
data from HTTP Archive. I picked the data
about images as well as JavaScript transfer
size. And from November of last year through
March of this year images--images on webpages
have gone bigger. There's more images and
they are getting bigger. These are for the--about
10,000 like top webpages on the web [INDISTINCT]
over 10,000. If you look at the JavaScript
it's also slowly growing into--in terms of
the amount of JavaScript that your browser
has to interpret and execute. Obviously, pages
are--on the web are getting richer. The Pickle
Page that used to have a little bit of HTML
and some nice style sheet is now a much more
complex web application. And one needs to
pay attention to the performance of these
pages because they directly relate to how
people approach and use the web, more data
from HTTP Archive that was released over a
month ago. If we look at things that we need
to pay attention to when optimizing webpages,
the--we can correlate that with the load time.
And if you look at column number 3, for example,
total requests are a direct--almost a direct
correlation with the load time. And there's
two pieces that you should always pay attention
to, which is the image transfer size. It has
a very good correlation with the load time
of the page. As well as at the end, the JavaScript
request, they're very well correlated with
the page load time. So when somebody pays
attention to optimization of images as well
as JavaScript, that helps a lot directly in
speeding up your webpages. And how does load
time impact success? Here's some data from
several websites out there. Amazon.com did
a study where they saw for every hundredth
millisecond latency decrease, they would increase
their revenue by 1%. You can imagine that
the scale of Amazon.com, that's quite a bit
of money. Edmunds.com worked with us last
year. They were working on optimizing their
webpages. They used Page Speed to look at
how they can optimize their pages and this
resulted to about 50% load time, load time
decrease. The impact on this was about 17%
page views per session. And who wouldn't want
to increase their pages? This is by focusing
on speed alone. Strangeloop Networks which
builds boxes that allow you to optimize webpages
on the fly. Did some analysis on consumer
behavior and they looked at like the consumer
behavior of a three second delay on what would
happen? And for 100 consumer visits, three
second delays would make sure that about--little
bit under 60% of people will just drop off
and leave your website. About 50% of them
will not return to your website. And that's
very important. And worse than this, they're
going to tell others not to go to your website.
So paying attention to speed is critical for--to
your success on the web. So I'd like to welcome
Andrew to talk about Page Speed Online API.
>> OATES: Thanks. Hi, I'm Andrew Oates. I
work on the Page Speed Team based out of Cambridge.
And I'm going to talk about the brand new
Page Speed Online API. So first, a little
bit of background of the Page Speed Project.
Page Speed is a tool that helps web developers
speed up their websites by applying sort of
well known web performance best practices.
We launched in 2008 originally as a Firefox
Extension. And then in 2009, we released the
Page Speed SDK which lets you sort of build
tools on top of the Page Speed library. Then
most recently, we launched the Chrome Extension
and Page Speed Online. And so the way Page
Speed work is we have a collection of rules.
Each of which encapsulates a single best practice.
Something like minifying your resources or
optimizing your images or doing asynchronous
patches. By one sort of piece of consistent
feedback we've gotten from developers is that
they want a way to run the Page Speed analysis
on their sites and get back sort of an easy
to consume machine readable format and do
this really easy without having to load up
a browser and script it or to do a compile
against the SDK. And so that's what we're
launching today. It's a new online API that
lets you do that. How does it work? It's super
simple. So you can see it at the top, you
the developer make a simple HTTP request to
our servers. Give us a URL to fetch, we will
go out and fetch and render that URL, then
run the Page Speed library on it and then
give you back the results in sort of a standard
JSON format. So here's an example. The top
is just a URL you might fetch from. So googleapis.com/pagespeedonline/v1/runpagespeed,
URL equals--give a URL and then the key equals
your developer keys. So if you've worked with
Google APIs before, you're familiar with the
developer keys. Based with a token that you
used to authenticate your request and lets
you control and track your usage. And I also
have little Python snippet here that illustrates
how you could use it in a language. The response
looks like this, standard JSON. We have the
URL you passed in, a response code and title.
We give you the Page Speed score. So if you're
not familiar with Page Speed, the Page Speed
scores and numbers, 0 to 100, it basically
says "How well are you doing?" Low score is
bad. You have a lot of room for improvement
and a high score is good. You're, you know,
applying lots of the best practices that we
know about. We're using stats about your webpage
and then down in this format results block,
we have a chunk for each rule that we apply.
So avoid bad requests, I guess, google.com
didn't have any bad requests. So we got a
hundred on that. And then this, you know,
continues on, past the bottom of the slide.
So that's all of my slides. Let's do a demo
because that's what we're all here about.
All right. So first, let's just take a look
at the request response. So I'll take it out.
So here we're going to run Page Speed on www.google.com
and that's my developer key, don't steal it.
And here's the result. All right. So we fetch
it, we got a 200, still get a 99 from when
I made the slide. And you can see here these--all
those rules I was telling you about. So avoid
bad requests, avoid CSS import, defer parsing
of JavaScript, et cetera and looks like here's
one that we fail, Minify HTML. So we get 99
on. That's still pretty good. And then we
have these sort of chunks that let you format
this. So this will be great if you're building
a tool to present to the users. And actually
if you use Page Speed Online or any of the
Page Speed products, we use this exact same
API and sort of various forms internally.
So you can build the same tools that we have.
We're also launching with the 40 language
support. So let say locale=korean. Oh, and
hey avoid, bad request. That's how you say
avoid bad request in Korean, I guess, I don't
speak Korean. So now, I'm going to show you
a quick demo of how you could use this in
your development environment. So I put together
a little website, "Andrew's vacation photos."
And it's my vacation photos. Really simple,
has some images on them, since CSS. Let's
take a look at what it looks like. Well, it's
five images but I really care about web performance.
I want people who come to see my vacation
photos to have a really snappy experience.
So I have the script, I call it push_and_test.py.
And basically what it does is it lets me push
a new version of the site to App Engine, this
is hosted on App Engine. And then tested to
an AV comparison against the old version and
see what's changed. So you can--don't worry
about the push version script, that does some
fancy stuff with hashes in the App Engine
environment. And now I have this function
test URL that basically, it reads the webpage
and counts number of image tags and make sure
that it's greater than two. So let's give
this a shot. Push_and_test.py. Ah, and there
were no changes. Testing, okay, great. Now
let's see how we can integrate the Page Speed
tool with this. So is that a function? If
you don't know Python, you should be able
to follow along. Anyways it's pretty simple.
GetPageSpeedResults, taken a target URL, it's
the URL of the site we want to analyze. So
let's split up our URL parameters. Target_url
and my developer key, which I don't remember.
So you can get this if you go to the APIs
console. Just sign up. Enable Page Speed Online
API and we're live right now. And you can
get your own developer key and then try this
out. All right. So now to construct our URL.
So we want https://www.googleapis.com/pagespeedonline/v1/runpagespeed
which is the only thing we can do. And then
we're just going to encode that URL parameters
as a string. All right. Let's fetch that URL,
and then let's parse it to JSON. So I like
Python a lot because you can do this pretty
easily. Load string response. All right. So
you can see, I have two URLs here: andrews-vacation-photos
and 0.latest.andrews-vacation-photos. I'll
explain that the next time we're waiting for
App Engine. So, let's get our Page Speed results
for both of those. Analyzing old page, stable
URL. Analyzing the new page and lets do test
URL. And we can delete this old stuff. All
right. So let's just make sure this will work.
And let's print out the results that we get.
And let's give it a shot. And like the old
page, analyzing the new page and that looks
like JSON, awesome. You notice it takes a
few seconds because we have to fetch the page
and render it and do all this analysis on
it. So now let's look at the Page Speed score.
So let's say if the old result's score is
greater than the new result score, score decreased,
it's a hard word. And then we'll print the
old results and the new results. Otherwise,
we're doing okay. We haven't introduced any
regressions. And let's print the page we'd
score for good measure. Old results, all right.
Oh, new results. Thank you. Feel free to speak
up if I screw up. All right. Analyze the old
page, new page, okay. Page Speed score 84.
Okay. So I have some room for improvement.
But I haven't introduced any problems which
is true because I haven't made any changes.
So let's make a change. Let's say I want to
adjust my site up with some jQuery and I have
it comment it out here because I can't remember
the URL. So we're going to load from the Google
hosted version. If you've used it before you
might notice I'm not loading the minified
version, that's my mistake. And we'll see
why in a second. Type rules. And let's say
whenever you mouse over an image, let's give
it a red boarder because I like gaudy things.
[INDISTINCT]. All right. Let's push and test.
Okay, so here's the App Engine magic. So App
Engine lets you upload multiple versions of
a site. So I'm using that to my advantage
here because I'm uploading one version but
keeping the old version around. And then I
can do an AV comparison. That does an exponential
back up. Okay? Analyzing old page, analyzing
new page, score decreased 84 to 74. Lets just
double check and make sure that its doing
what I think its doing. Refresh. Yes, that's
working, for some definition of working. Score
decreased 84 to 74. So in this case, it's
pretty simple to figure what I did wrong.
I only added one chunk, right? But let's say
I did a really complex change and I want to--I
want to know more about what's going, so I
can do that. So let's go back to the script,
okay. So let's add a new function. Let's call
it compare results. It's the old results,
new results, and as you saw briefly, we give
the results, they're formatted and then we
have the structure called rule results which
is a dictionary which map from rule names
to result blocks, so we add it for the new
and the old. All right, so now, let's say,
for every page speed rule in the old one--in
the old results and I was going to assume
that the page speed library didn't change
between these two implications. It's a fair
assumption for this demo. Let's say if the
old--get the result block and let's say rule
score, so we also assign the score to each
rule, is the gray of them, the same thing
in the new results block that means of this
rule, the score is decreased, so it's a pretty
good bet that this is the chain that's causing
a problem. Let's print a rule is triggered.
And then let's give the localized name of
the rule, so if you were--if you're making
this--if you're making this tool to publish
for instance, you could the grab the locale
out of--from the client and they would see
these strings, well, not the strings you're
writing but any page with strings they would
see in whichever the locale you choose. All
right, I think that will work. All right,
so if old results score, grade a new results
scores, let's also do compare results, old
results, new results. All right, cross your
fingers. And there's old and there's new score,
decreased 84-74, rule triggered Defer parsing
of JavaScript and Minify JavaScript. Okay,
so some of you do a JavaScript. Let's say
that I only have a few minutes. I really want
to fix something, which one of these is more
important. Well, page speed can tell us. We
also sign something called an impact to each
rule. So basically, the score will tell you
how badly did you do on this rule. So you
get a zero on a rule, right? That means that
you're doing really badly on it but if it
only affects one teeny tiny part of your page,
you probably don't care that much. There could
be another rule that you did okay on, maybe
got a 75 but it affects a large portion of
your page and you will get a lot more out
of fixing that and that's what the impact
means. So let's add the impact here. So we
know which one--what we want to fix. It's
going to run over in my line, so new rule
results, get the rule and rule impact. And
all of this is documented. You can just stick
in and play around and take a look at it,
they're also all documented on the code site.
So let's try again, oops, will that change?
Did I not close my bracket? Well, that's odd,
I think let's try this in a four set push
new version again and see, so let's check
to make sure it's--hey, it's still doing the
add jQuery thing. So we say caching headers
on the page speed responses, so if there was
weird cache in between page speed and me right
now that might--there we go, perfect. Okay,
score decrease 84-74. Rules triggered Defer
parsing JavaScript, impact 1.0 whatever. Minify
JavaScript impact 9.3. Okay, so Minify JavaScript
has a lot more impact on my page in deferring
parsing event. So let's focus on fixing that.
So let's edit, index I can move back up I
forgot to use minified version. Fortunately,
I can just add that. So minification, if you
don't know, is basically process of removing
anything extra, so your JavaScript file will
have, you know, comments in white space, that
aren't necessarily the [INDISTINCT] JavaScript,
but necessary for reading it, so when you
minify, you strip all that out and you can
make your page run a lot faster or the resource
load a lot faster. Now, let's run it and see
what happens. It's going to push again, waiting
two seconds, four seconds and this is really
a simple example, so we're designing this
so people can build page speed like tools.
Okay, page speed score 86, so we fixed the
problem. You also notice the score, it's a
little cut off, that's okay. The score went
up a little bit. The reason for that is we
made our page heavier. We got--we added a
whole bunch of JavaScript to it and so as
a result any deficiencies that we have before
sort of matter less of the grand scheme of
things that's why our page speed score went
by a few points. And so that's an example
of how in just a few minutes, we--I integrated
the API, build this regression testing tool
that will help me catch these performance
bugs, you know, maybe I would have launched
the site without realizing it. I would have--two
months later found out that I've been losing
traffic because of this regression. All right,
let's go back to presentation. We lost our
place. So we're launching us today, you can
go try that now. Also launching today is W3
Total Caches is adding Integration with us,
so here's the screen shot that the [INDISTINCT]
cache on us, showing--this is the exact same
UI that we have in all of our page speed products.
We integrated it with the page speed online
API and just inserted it right into this performance
dash board. And that's a sort of--that's a
sort of part of integration and tools we want
to encourage with this. It's basically lower
the barrier to entry to using the page speed
library in a tools and work flows and a lot
of the good stuff. If you want to learn more,
that's a giant Q, our code for our docs. as
well as the actual URL and the goo.goalurl
you can scan that in and get started right
away and that's all I have. Going to hand
it off to Shawn who will talk about mod_pagespeed.
>> LIGOCKI: Hey, how are you guys doing? I'm
Shawn Ligocki and I'll be talking about mod_pagespeed.
Now--mod_pagespeed is--the idea is to automate
some of these rules--these page speed best
practices on a server so that you don't have
to do it yourself. Right now it's the Apache
Web server plug in and it reverts your HTML
and your resources and it's an open source
product. You might ask, "Why do I need to
use mod_pagespeed?" Can't I just implement
all these optimizations myself? And there's
a couple of reasons you might want have something
automated but one of them is that a number
of these things specifically I'm going to
be talking about leveraging browser caching
and combining images into CSS sprites can
be kind of difficult to do and specifically
to maintain if you do them yourself. And so
to talk about this little bit, I'm going to
go in some detail about why you want to do
it in the first place. So the first one is
our extend cache filter and this is--the basic
idea here is you have a cache so by default,
your cache lifetime for most resources is
going to be that five minutes. And here's
an example of what happens. This is the initial
request the user makes to your website and
this is going to be covering a single resource
so one image on your site, one CSS file. And
then here's the response that comes back and
you can see kind of response, there's a lot
of content there because it's a whole image
or whole CSS file. And then if your user then
goes ahead and visits the site again, maybe
let's say four minutes later, they're actually
going to make no request all the way to the
server because they still have the resource
cache in their browser. But if they go visit
let's say six minutes later, they're going
to have to go and ping your server and say
this resource is [INDISTINCT] out of the cache,
is it still good and your server has to response
back saying, yup it's still good, 304 not
modified. And this kind of repeats forever
as they come to visit your site again and
again over the next, you know, minutes, hours,
days, each time they visit after five minutes
is going to have another response. And you
might say, you know, this is just a really
simple request response. It should be really
short but it's a whole round trip which can,
you know, be tens, hundreds of milliseconds
and as Richard pointed out, there can be,
you know, 50 images, hundreds of resources
on your site if each one has these round trips,
it's expensive. And so--and the best practice
is to have longer caching lifetimes. So what
if you just set your cache lifetime to one
year? You know it looks great, right? I mean,
you know, you have--there's nothing, you load
it the first time, you have to and there's--you
never have to go connect the server again.
And you know, it sounds perfect except of
course--what if you ever changed that file?
And if you change it, just say like 13 minutes
after, you know, the user visit the first
time. They might not notice for another year
as it stays in their browser cache, you know,
probably less than that but maybe like, you
know, week, a day and anything like that,
you--that whole time if your JavaScript, let's
say you fixed an error in it or you updated
the versions of your JavaScripts, now they're
going to be out of date. So most people when
they--when they put cache headers on their
files, they put reasonably short cache headers
and the reason is that now let's say here's
the--again the five minutes, you know, sure
you're doing these pings every once in a while,
this time the ping really matters. This time
the ping tells you, you should really update
your request and download the new resource.
So a question you might want to know is, "Well,
can we get both?" Can we get the best of both
worlds, so that we don't have to keep pinging
the server when the thing's not updated. But
we can ping it and get the actual results.
Get the new updated resource when it is updated
and that's exactly what we've done in mod_pagespeed.
So for the whole that it hasn't been updated,
you don't do anything and then finally, when
it has been updated, you go ahead and ping
the server get the new response back and get
the updated resource. So that's sounds great,
how do you do it? We're going to go all detail
here. If this is the original thing, it's
just an image, walrus.png and now when we
rewrite it with my pagespeed, we're going
to change the URL. We're going to add--specifically
you're going to note hash code here, just
the 91_www and that's md5 hash of the content
of the file. And so every time this file changes,
you're going to have a different URL and so
it's going to tell the browser you have to
update. And so now, you can see that we can
add, you know, this is the original cache
lifetime, we waited five minutes to be--have
as much control over our website as possible.
And now we can extend that out to be a whole
year long. And whenever the file changes,
you know, here's the new--here's the new hash
code automatically when you load the new HTML
file, where you're going to get the new resource,
the new image, the new CSS. And that's how
we can avoid all these extra checks but still
get it updated after you updated your resource.
Another example I'm going to cover is a spraying
images. The idea here is that if you have,
you know, probably multiple images on your
site. Richard showed that the average site
has 50 images on each site. So here we just
have an example with three. Each one of these,
you're going to have to make a request out
to the server and a response back, that's
a roundtrip and then get the results and another
request out, response back at the results.
And in addition each time, the user visits
the site again after some number of--some
time past the caching date, it's going to
have to make this again three roundtrips for
each of the images or 50 roundtrips if you
have 50 images. So you'd like to be able to
just get rid of all the extra roundtrips to
say I want to request all the images and get
them all back. And then each time I can just
make a single ping to say, you know, is this
still up to date. And that's exactly what
we do except in addition of course, we also
cache extend it and so you don't even have
to do those extra pings until the images actually
change. And how do you do this? Well, in this
case, you know, here, let's say this is the
original page, this is the original CSS file
and you have, you have these two PNGs here
in different backgrounds. And now when you--we've
written the page, you have them both come
out together into a single URL, it's repeated
twice here. That's one, you know, resource
is going to be loaded and each of these have
offsets to show you--to tell the CSS which
one to show. And so, you know, this is the
original images, these are just the two images
put together. And we do the same thing with
CSS files and JavaScript files to be able
to combine them to reduce the number of roundtrips
that we need to make to the server. Great.
So this is some of the motivation for why
you want to install a mod pagespeed, why you
want to automatically rewrite your web pages,
and so here's a little information about how
you could install it. If you're using Go Daddy
or DreamHost basic hosting, it's actually
already provided. All you need to do is sign
up with clicking a little check box or putting
in a small configuration file and you can
test it out. If you're using CentoS or Ubuntu
there is binary downloads you can put into
the package manager, it'll automatically update
themselves. And of course it's also open source
so it's available by--you build from--oops,
you can build from source using instruction
on the website. In addition, as soon as you
download it, it will already start rewriting
your webpage in a way that we think are both
safe and really useful for your site. So it
has kind of a core set of filters enabled
to rewrite your site. But in addition, we
provide lots of configurability, you can do
number of things, you know, simple things
like turning web page speed off so you can
just do it for testing. You can change the
default instead rewrite level to more conservative
or liberal levels. And you can turn on and
off individual rewrite passes to do things
like removing comments to spreading images,
things like that. There's some more detailed
configuration options you can do. If you're
one of the--a big help that mod pagespeed
can provide is rewriting images if you have
large images that are represented in small
size in your webpage, you can really resize
those. And even if they are the same size,
often you'll have extra information that's
unnecessary so we can run through opt PNG,
another optimization software to reduce the
size of the images. But that's kind of an--it
can be CPU intensive so you can reduce--you
can set the number of images to be rewritten
at the same time. And there's other things
you can set up to pinging your local architectures.
Great. Let's say--so now that you've installed
mod pagespeed, you might want to know how
do I really know that it's helping my page.
And this is what we love to get your feedback
and see how it's working for you guys. And
we have two examples that we're suggesting
for how you can go and check this. And the
first one is Page Speed Online, it's the tool
that Andrew's team released a couple of months
ago. And you just go to the website and input
your URL and it tells you what the page speed
score for your site and some suggestions that
you want to follow. And so by using that before
and after, you can get some feel how much
is it actually implementing those decisions,
is it improving your page speed score. And
addition you probably want to know how much
is it actually speeding up your site. And
so webpage test is a nice website that allows
you to actually go and load using an IE browser
in a real location along cable modem or something
like that. And to actually see how long it
takes for the page to load, how--you can see
the waterfall diagrams and all the details
about it. And so I'm going to cover--I'm going
to actually through and demo some of these
to show you how you can test this. So here's
Page Speed Online and in this case, we're
going to be testing one of our user sites
which is
Androidacademy and we're going to set it first
to get a baseline with page speed turned off.
[PAUSE] Great. And so here you can see that,
you know, the page speed score is 69. And
here they have some examples of things that
you might want to do on the website to make
it faster. So specifically here, I noticed,
you know, it's leverage browser caching and
combining which is CCS sprites and these two
other things I just mentioned that--one page
we can help you with and in addition there's
also a yellow one for inline small CSS files
which we also do. So now we go ahead and let's
say we can open this in a new window so we
can compare them and let's try loading just
a page with no [INDISTINCT] so that we get
the actual mod page speed version. And--great.
[PAUSE] So, as you could see, I mean, this
increased all the way to 79 points, it's up
10 points which is almost, you know, 15% to
20% and in addition, the leverage browser
caching is down to a yellow item. The inline
CSS is gone. You'll notice that that combine
images of the CSS sprites is still here. You
might ask me why is that I just mentioned
it, inline images in CSS sprites is a new
feature that we're releasing. We haven't worked
all the details yet and we haven't suggested
people's turn on yet. So that's kind of an
example of something that we can still be
working on for the site to provide value to
it. And for the leverage browser caching,
so, you know, you might say, "Well, we reduced
it from, you know, a red item to a yellow
item but it's still on there. Why is it on
there?" if we could just leverage all the
browser caching. But if we look at this a
little bit we can see, glancing at this, there's
maybe 15 or 20 of these guys. It seems like
that's kind of a lot, you know, things we
haven't been able to increase the cache lifetime
on. But look at the original one, it's actually
like, you know, 40 to 50 maybe 100 of these.
There's quite a number. And so we've made
a significant improvement. Each of these again
is like a roundtrip when you visit the site
again. And so reducing it, you know, from
100 down to 20 is 80% improvement of that
kind of load time in some ways. In addition--probably
what's happening here for these why these
aren't being inlined, they're probably something
in an ajax poll or a JavaScript that's--we
can't find when we're rewriting the page.
And if that's the case then it's probably
actually not so bad because if they're in
an ajax call, that's probably after the pages
are reloaded and so it's not going to impede
sort of using the page that they're not cache
extended, might be a pretty good thing. So--so,
yeah, here you can--you can go back and look
for some reason, you can compare these as
one way of seeing your optimization were.
But--another example--but you might say your
mod pagespeed of course, you're going to improve
the page speed score, what does that really
tell me? And so it's, you know, another good
example to go check out is webpage test which
like I mentioned. We'll actually go and load
this page from a real browser. You can choose
whether you want to load it from IE, from
Chrome, and there's a number of different
locations, you can pick one where you think
your users is going to be or test different
locations in the U.S. and internationally.
And specifically we'd suggest if you're doing
this, you up the number of runs, because one
run doesn't give you very good statistical
significance. You could have a bad run, bad
network things like that. And so we'd, you
know, suggest you up it to about 10 which
is the maximum. And to see it will tell you
all the different runs. You can see the distribution
of it and it will all specifically point out
so the median--the median time which is kind
of what your average you usually see. I'm
not going to run this one live because there's
kind of a queue for waiting for this and so
it could take, you know, maybe 10, 20 minutes
to run through. But I have some examples saved
here. This is also from Android Academy. Here's
the before, and as you can see at the top
here, we have a bunch of metrics about load
times, start render, first [INDISTINCT], things
like that, and the number of request size.
And if we look down here, we can see the waterfall
diagrams. And the first one here is--is the
initial load, and the second one here is the
return load. You can see there's less resources,
I know it's all hard to see because it's in
little pages. Less resource loaded this time.
All the yellow ones are the ones I was mentioning
earlier. This is--when you just ping the server
and it says, the resource hasn't changed,
so in some ways, it's all but wasted and you
can see that it actually takes quite a bit
of time to do all those yellow responses.
And you go through these 10 responses here.
This is the after words. And if we just glance
down, add some of these results, we can see
that, let's say, this repeat view is much
more. And you know, presumably, what we've
done here is eliminate all these pings we
have to make back to the server for these
sub--sub-resources by extending their cache
lifetimes. And so, now you know--and you can
see specifically, it's not just from the image
but the actual hard numbers here. There's
42 requests made on the repeat view, after
we turned on one Page Speed. And if you go
back to the original one with mod pagespeed
off, there's 95. So, it's less than half of
the number of requests, and that can make
a big difference. And you know it's not just
the number of requests. If you look at the
start rendered time here, it's 3.2 seconds,
afterwards it's 1.2 seconds, I mean, it's
even less than half the time to first, get
the first paint on the screen and let your
user know that something is happening. And
the finish time here, afterwards is 3.6 seconds,
before it was 6.1, again about half the time.
So, is this you know--it's actually--it's
pretty significant change in--in how much
loading time if you have used, I mean, back
again to your site.
And so--and so, we'd love to hear, you guys
telling us about how--if you--if you get a
chance to install this on your site and to
run through some of these tests and see how
it works for you, how it improves your sites,
et cetera. And if you'd like more information,
all things--kind of the center for all things,
Page Speed, so the URL appears, it comes with
a search for us. In addition, we'll be having
sort of office hours down in Pub Lounge which
is right down at the bottom of the stairs,
take a left, where people were eating lunch
today. We'll be there until 6:00 P.M. for
one on one. And in addition, if you're interested
in these topics, if you check out there is
two talks tomorrow at Google IO, Josh Marantz,
giving one on Mod Page Speed, tomorrow at
11:30, and Bryan McQuade is giving one on
"Page Speed for Mobile Browsers," and that's
going to be in the afternoon, 3:45.
>> OATES: So actually, I have a second demo
that we weren't going to do but we have time,
more for it, we have about 20 minutes. So
I'm going to show you the advanced features
of the Page-Speed Online API. And by advanced,
I mean, everything that's left. And I'm going
to attempt to build an entire Page Speed tool
in the next 15 minutes and you guys can help.
Yeah, whoever that was, thank you. All right,
so let's take a look at--let's take a look
at what the--the results look like. So, before
we were just looking at the rule names, but
as you can see--where is that rule thing?
So, as you can see, we have a lot more than
just a rule name here, right? We have a rule
score, and impact, there's URL blocks, and
there's header, and the format, and these
args. Basically this is what we use in Page
Speed Online, and Page Seed Chrome, and Page
Speed Firefox to construct the actual UI.
And it's really simple. How it works is this,
we have, um, these format strings. The following
external resources have smaller response [INDISTINCT]
in line with the resources--that's a bad example.
Let's do this one, "$1 should inline the following
small resources:" and then we have, oh, yeah,
an argument, "type": "URL" "value" that. So,
basically as a developer, you can just stick
in this, this URL in the place for the dollar
one. Is there are better example? And what
that lets you do is--here we go. So here's
the list of resources that have--that don't
have--that don't have cache left times. So,
I mean, $1 and a $2. $1 is the URL, Andrews
vacation photos, media, photo1. That's the
shells, I think. And then the duration, 10
minutes. And what--this lets you do by giving
me this flexible format. It lets you format
things differently. So, for instance in Page
Speed Online, what we do is we take these
URL arguments and we turn them into links.
These are--can click on to go to a different
thing. And I think we bold durations or we
italicize them or something like that. So,
it's a really flexible format, um, so let's
extend our script to use these. So, let's
just do a--what's it called? Print--let's
just do print results, so let's take in some
page PrintResults and I'll print them out
in a flexible format. So, and again it's what
you leverage our [INDISTINCT] language support
so that your users all over the world can--can
see this in the language of their choice--the
locale of their choice. All right, so, let's
see. This is--okay, so we're going to get
the rule results from, as we did before. Results
equal--equals results--format results. The
same thing we did up top there. And for every
rule in the Rule Results--let's just print
out a header. Rule Results--rule LocalizedRuleName.
PrintResults, let's just print out whatever
the new results are. Push and test, oops,
analyzing old, analyzing new. Okay, list of
rule names. Let's augment that. So, I'm actually
going to just comment this out for now. We're
just going to print the--the Page Speed results.
And we have--we're going to have Snippets,
examples posted online for JavaScript and
Pythons--some other common languages for how
to--how to do these things. All right, so,
if you look at--this is my save version in
case the Internet broke. If you look at this
Rule Result Block, we have the name of the
rule there, a localized rule name in these
urlBlocks thing, and when the URL block sees--it's
chunks of URLs that are related. So, for instance,
you might have one urlBlock per redirect chain.
You would say, this redirect chain should
be eliminated. This redirect chain should
be eliminated and so on and so forth. So for
urlBlock in Rule Results, rule urlBlocks--so
let's just printout the header. Oops, this
is the danger of a live demo, that has not
been rehearsed. urlBlocks header. For urlBlock,
end rule, results rule, urlBlocks. Are there
any Python gurus who want to pipe up and tell
me what I'm doing wrong?
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> OATES: Oh, yeah, there we--well, that's--that's
a possibility. Well, let's test and see if
urlBlocks. There we go. Thank you, Bryan.
So, let's--let's do some more interesting
page, actually. Let's do it on, news.google.com.
And again, bear with me, [PAUSE] this is a
little by the seat of my pants. Okay. [PAUSE]
Bryan, this is my manager Bryan, he's helping
me up.
>> Actually we need [INDISTINCT].
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Say that, again?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> OATES: Bingo. "Analyzing," there we go.
Okay. So, you can see if which one of these
headers we have a "format" which is the string.
And we optionally have some "args." So, let's
write a little function to fill that in, "FillFormatString."
Let's just call it "header," "if," somebody
just beeped at me. Oh, it's right on time.
[PAUSE] All right otherwise, "for" each "argument"
"in" the "header" and this is pretty [INDISTINCT].
We have examples of this online. [PAUSE] There
we go. I already have this written. This felt
familiar. Oops, all right. "FillFormatString
(format_string_dictionary)." So, [INDISTINCT]
instead of putting in the "header," let's
print out, "FillFormatString" "header." Let's
see what that looks like. Oops. "Analyzing
page," "Analyzing page." [PAUSE] Isn't it
fun watching people debug? All right. "If
"args" not in format_string_dictionary: return
format_string_dictionary['format']." Cross
your fingers for me. Damn, "args = format_string."
This is clearly buggy code. [PAUSE] "(format_string_dictionary['args']):
out = sub(i+1) args[i], out) return out."
Well, then this is on 108, 98, 82. [PAUSE]
On hash, we'll type "dictionary." "FillFormatString(url_block),
170, thank you. [PAUSE] What was there again?
The high calibrated Google Engineers illustrated
in front of everyone, 170. All right, we got
sub, "args," this is infuriating. Oh, right.
So, we have a type in a value for each of
these. This needs to be the value. Oops, let's
see if that works. And there we go. Okay,
awesome. That was harder than it should have
been. It's going to be so smooth now. All
right, "Minifying the following JavaScripts
resources could reduce their size by 2.3 kilobytes
(0% reduction). So, it worked. So, let's indent
that. All right, now let's look at the results
and dig down a little further. So, in this
URL block, we have the header. And then we
also have optionally this list of URLs here.
Each one of these has a result. And the result
is the exact same format as the header. So,
"if 'urls' in url_block: for url in url_block['urls']."
There's a better way to do this on Python
but I'm not going to bother with that right
now, "if 'result' in url: print "1, 2, 3,
4, 5" why not?"+ FillFormatString(url['result'])"
Knock on wood. There we go. So, "The following
cacheable resources have a short freshness
lifetime. Specify expiration at least one
week in the future for the following resources."
And if we reach this, we give a URL and that.
All right, there's one more step, as our indentation
gets further and further, "if 'details' in
url: for detail in url['details']: print "1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7" + FillFormatString(detail),"
"push_and_test," "Analyzing," looks good.
Let's do one more thing instead of doing that
URL. Let's take it in from "argv," "(argv[1])."
Because now we're going to "push_and_test,"
give me a URL, anyone. Let's do Android Academy,
www.androidacademy.com. Drum roll, takes a
while, "Analyzing," and there we go. Page
speed results, I did that in 8 minutes. You
can do better, I'm sure. Thank you.
>> RABBAT: Please join here back. So, we're
all--so, Shawn and Andrew was showing you
many simulations of what your page speed would
be like webpage test is a nice simulation
of what your webpage latency would be. Last
week on Thursday, Google analytics announced
that now if you have Google Analytics on your
site and you add one line to your site, we
actually collect your site speed and show
it to you in the dashboard, in the Google
Analytics dashboard. And that will be a great
help for you as you see the real world at,
you know, client side latency that you expect,
that you want to see as opposed to, you know,
the several size where webpage test servers
are or some localized--localized pages. So,
we have a few minutes if you have any questions,
please go ahead.
>> Yes.
>> RABBAT: Yes.
>> So, we can view this online at page speed--that
was page speed [INDISTINCT] in different sites
which are only the way to a certain rules.
And then you get [INDISTINCT] users with your
page speed to work. Some elements are just
[INDISTINCT].
>> OATES: So, for page speed to online specifically,
we actually don't take the amount of the number
or seconds that it takes to load the page
into account. One for page speed online, it's
Google loading in it. And Google has a lot
of fast Internet connections so it wouldn't
be a representative. For another thing, our
focus--so, there are tools that have to do
that. For instance, web page test is, sort
of a full solution. And it will give you stats
for the actual page load time. But for...
>> LIGOCKI: And you can, and you can go ahead
and load that from trying--they have servers
all over the world.
>> OATES: Yes. So, for page speed itself,
we're focused more on what, sort of, irrespective
of this like connect--the actual connection
you're on. You know, how, what kind of server
you're running if you did have more boxes
on the backend. What can you do on the client
side for these development best practices
to speed up your site?
>> LIGOCKI: Although you still also have specific
rules for mobile sites, fort his specific
different way to weigh things.
>> OATES: Yes, yes. So, one thing we launched
recently with page speed online and Brian
and Levo are going to talk about this at IO
tomorrow is new specific new page speed rules.
So, Mobile's obviously a big growing space
and phone connections are really slow. There's--and
RTTs will be in the order of seconds instead
of milliseconds. And so every connection you
save, every request can have a huge impact
on your site in terms of views, revenue, etc.
And so we launched a new, some new rules in
the mobile space to help people optimize with
the situations.
>> RABBAT: Any more questions? Yes.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> LIGOCKI: Yes. So, lot of what we were looking
at right now, and we're testing this is how
do we choose which images we should be spreading
together and how we should be doing this.
And in general right now, we're focusing mostly
on images that are already in the CSS, already
in--written in CSS. And so what that means
is you foreground images listed in the image
tag, those are more likely to be probably
important user experience to load early. If
you can combine a bunch of very small images
that are like part of your Chrome, your rounded
corners, little smiley faces, things like
that, that can be helpful. And it might not
even actually slow down the load of the whole
thing.
>> OATES: And for like a lot of these things,
it's a trade off, right?
>> LIGOCKI: Yes.
>> OATES: If--different connection types have
different characteristics, you might have
a really, something like a 3G or a 4G connection
on a phone, can have actually a fair amount
bandwidth but really high RTTs, really high
latency. In that case, if you can just dump
everything down with one request, you'll save
a lot of time rather than having to go back
and forth to the server for each one of those
small images. And so finding where that trade
off is, is sort of, an important part of the
process.
>> RABBAT: Okay. All right, well thank you
very much. And we hope you enjoy the rest
of IO Boot Camp.